how old covet 19 redefined what the
European Union is all about hello
everyone for France 24 I'm false puppy
Calvin Paris and I'm Melinda crane for
Deutsche Welle in Berlin in the European
Union health care has always been
handled at the national level so as the
corona pandemic swept the continent
it was nation-states that were calling
the shots even between close EU
neighbours borders were closed crucial
medical exports were stopped and
solidarity was looking pretty illusory
but that is now changing with French
patients for example being treated in
German hospitals
yeah and Melinda with a crisis that were
two months into which some are calling
the biggest test for this continent
since World War two a lot of questions
going forward the French president menya
in Macomb calling it a moment of truth
ahead of Thursday's virtual summit there
are those that are eyeing dick Dee
confinement and then other nations that
are doubling down what common response
can France and Germany often dubbed the
motor of European unity a rally a
continent that's sure to face some major
major challenges both within the
European Union and from the rest of the
world
our title today is corona Europe's
moment of truth frost
Beckett and Deutsche Welle TV join up
for the debate welcome and joining us
from Frankfurt he's the former deputy
mayor there former student leader may 68
and former co-leader of the Green Party
in the European Parliament thank you so
much Daniel cohn-bendit for being with
us hi
and joining us from his Berlin office is
matam fond marshal he's a member of the
German Bundestag representing Freiburg
which lies close to the French border
and he's also a member of the
franco-german Parliamentary Assembly
welcome thank you
from Stas boo on the banks of the Rhine
we are pleased to welcome dr. Shah Mac
Agha Baba a doctor you're an emergency
physician and
also member of the municipal council
thank you for being with us thank you
over the past weeks you've been doing a
lot less politics and a lot more of your
quote unquote day job I know you've been
working out of the emergency dispatch it
should be pointed out to our viewers ads
ask the region that borders Germany is
one of the big clusters here in France
originally it was down in the southern
part of ANZUS in the city of me lose but
you also have been feeling the brunt of
it
we know that the curve is flattened
what's the situation like this Tuesday
well this situation is a stabilization
in the number of people tested positive
the Cavett 19-under stabilization of the
number of people being hospitalized
right and maybe we tell hope in people
transfer in ICU which is 10 percent less
than the other days so we we still have
people going to the hospital we still
have people testing positive we still
have severe cases by the number of
people dying and the number of people
going to the ICU is declining
Shameka Gabourey when you first saw the
cases coming out of China coming out of
Italy did you think
Alsace would be hit so hard now never we
we had the same image at first the image
that we had from SARS or from MERS in
the early 2000 and we we thought that we
can have something about maybe 10 cases
in stress word and then in something
like a week we saw people coming we saw
first elderly people undone younger
people with very severe cases and we saw
people dying and we saw people being
transferred to ICU need the meat of ICU
beds and then we were really surprised
but no one of our colleagues were
thinking that
pandemics were coming at this race in
our region let me pick up with a
question - Mattin fun marshal whose
electoral district is just right across
the Rhine River from that Alsace region
that as we have just heard was hit very
early and very hard bike ovid so mr.
Quon marshal what has that meant for the
people in your district and for your
region as a whole that was and still is
very difficult for our region you should
probably know that about 40,000 people
from Alsace move to my region to suit
Baden to work basically but they all
work in very important places like for
example hospitals so we absolutely need
these people and as a sudden they they
couldn't come but also because we
decided to close the border as Oz's was
defined as a high-risk area why was it
defined high-risk area because the
infection spread exactly in that
specific Ria's rural south of colmar and
directed to me Lewis because there was a
church event with several thousand
people and these people they were very
close together and sort of the virus
spread very fast in that area now just
these days we can come back to slightly
open the borders again which is very
important for our common life and I hope
and we will bring this topic into a
meeting of the committee of cross-border
cooperation where I a member from the
Georgia Buddhist AG in this cross-border
cooperation this will be a video
conference this Thursday and a very much
hope that we cannot convince both sides
Germany and France to make a
cross-border cooperation more easy in
the near future
Daniel cohn-bendit franco-german
cooperation well that's literally in
your DNA because you're the citizen of
both countries how do you think your two
nations have risen to the challenge
difficult it's difficult because for the
French it's difficult to see that it
seems that it's easier to be in Germany
and that they handle the covet or the
covet is not so explosive or less
explosive that in France and because in
this pandemic a push train a tional
reaction so if so safety sanity safety
it's a national thing and so the
cooperation is it's not good it's not
good it's difficult and I think that the
French and the German government is not
doing it well it's not doing it till
today yeah they did some wonderful
things there was you know transfer from
France to Germany etc yes but even now
you know even if you see the discussion
that we have now for the post pandemic
the economic recovery I think that
France and France in Germany are not on
the same track and if France and Germany
is not on the same track then it will be
very difficult in Europe we want to we
want to come back to that question just
a little bit later but let me go now to
doctor Simic by bayi because we just
heard from daniel cohn-bendit that in
fact there are many people in France who
have a sense that somehow the Germans
are doing it better we've seen some
surprising headlines coming out of
France lays a mangaka pourquoi sont en
mayor why are they better across the
world not only in Europe but all over
the world it seems that the corona virus
is exposing the gaps and deficits in
countries health systems and in their
economies so what would you say you have
seen about what needs to change in
France well what what I can say
the difference is first of all maybe it
will be an it is a difference on
counting the dead people because in
France all the dead people in this
period also indirect that people are
counted as copy that but in Germany if
you have diabetes or hypertension you
may be counted differently when I said
that I can explain all the difference in
the world the other part of the
difference is maybe about the number of
bed per capita than you have in Germany
I think it's something about eight bed
for one thousand inhabitants in front
it's five point nine and the number of
ICU bed that you have in Germany it's a
two or three times higher than in France
so that can explain because when you
have severe cases it's your ability to
have 20 natural mechanical ventilation
support to save people and if you have
more ICU bed and you have Mara more ICU
doctor and nurses well-trained then you
can save people so maybe one of the
first lessons it's that we need
efficient public health services in all
the countries in European Union around
the world and we need it urgently to
face other pandemics coming mechag a
bidet the French spend more per capita
on healthcare than the Germans why have
they less to offer as you've just
described it well because we had where
we accountants vision on health policy
in the last 20 years the last French
government was was really had a really
austerity policy unwelcome they closed
something about to 20,000 beds in five
years so at at some
at some moment you're gonna pay for this
because you need these beds for the
people and we in the emergency
departments we were saying that for
something about two or three days three
years that we need beds we need nurses
we need doctors and we need budget
spending on public health structures let
me say to Daniel cohn-bendit
I know you wanted to weigh in here we
want to just bring in a brief report and
then I'd like to come to you right after
that so even between close neighbors in
the European Union not only the effects
of the virus but also the responses to
it have diverged pretty widely the
lockdown restrictions here in Germany
for example were never as drastic as
those in France and in fact are now
slowly being relaxed my daughter Bella
colleague Machado de Kirchner has this
short report from Berlin four weeks into
nationwide contact restrictions the
government is beginning to loosen its
tight grip on public life and German
Chancellor Angela Merkel is cautioning
Germans to be responsible with their
regained freedoms Vindhya tranquil
oathean than their local we're now
lifting some of these restrictions but
we don't know exactly what the
consequences will be and that's why we
have to take this slowly step by step it
would be a great shame if we now
knowingly head it into real acting at
varying speeds German federal states are
allowing medium sized shops to open but
hotels and restaurants have to remain
closed people on the streets of Berlin
are torn between a sense of relief and
concern by lifting the restrictions can
go both ways it really depends on how
sensibly people behave now we do meet a
local woman
they're more sweeper life must go on I'm
not worried that people are going to
drop dead around me by Deloitte in
upstanding people just don't keep their
distance we cannot imagine how many walk
past just five centimetres away from me
that's done public backing for the
restrictions imposed has so far been
always upwards of 90% and Angela
Merkel's approval ratings have also
sought Germany's health system has so
far been spared being pushed to the
limit now that German Chancellor is
concerned that Germans may over
celebrate the easing of restrictions and
it will take at least two weeks until
she finds out so let me ask Danny
cohn-bendit do you share the
Chancellor's concern about a premature
relaxation of restrictions I know that
in a recent interview you praised her
leadership for example in comparison
with the martial rhetoric of President
McCall
yes internally she is doing well the
problem is when she doesn't talk about
Europe and what year we can discuss this
after I just want to - come back - the
difference between France and Germany I
think the critics on the German system
health system was exactly the same in
the wording before Korona that it was in
France we shops bad with shops hospitals
they have - they didn't have enough
nurse etc today the big difference is
the federal system the federal system is
stronger the if it's good manage and it
is good manage in Germany you have a
health minister in H every lender it's
why even if they have less money they
are they organize it better of lender of
this decentralized level and this is a
big difference between France and
Germany and I think a part of the German
society will be aware to continue to
keep the one and half two meters there
will be an
of love it's it's a problem but at the
end you can't lock down from months and
months the people the family don't you
can't do it a family with three kids in
a sixty metres apartment it's impossible
you can do it five weeks secret and then
then it will explode so the also also
the French have to understand that we
have to improve in distance in distance
etc but we have to open a little bit if
not the people will don't resist to go
out without any restriction because it's
too hard
may I may I just ask Matt on phone
Marshall to weigh in on this point are
you concerned about premature relaxation
of the restrictions well I feel that we
are members of parliament when we are in
discussions with the people of our
regions of our constituencies we are
facing high pressure especially from the
business people because they have been
that they couldn't have worked for the
last weeks I mean we have programs to
support them but let's say those who
sell goods and the cities those who run
restaurants hotels they are basically in
a very difficult situation and they urge
us to do most to do whatever we can do
to relax these these strict regulations
and I think for the moment being we are
going a smooth way we do it step by step
we we ask our people to to to cooperate
we try to avoid you know strict measures
of course if there is big parties we
must be strict but we try to take the
people with us and try to make them
sensitive due to the fact that we will
not overcome the crisis in a few weeks
but we will need to wait until we have
medicament
vaccinations and this will take probably
all of almost about a year so we must as
Daniel cohn-bendit says get used to a
certain culture of distant behavior I
think we can manage this we can manage
it in supermarkets but it's it's a hard
way of which also might be if I may say
so different in Latin countries in
Mediterranean countries and in no more
northern countries because we have
different absorbs of let's say being
close together our physical distance is
different intelligence in countries I
think we are in between and in southern
Germany we are somewhat more a legend
but let me I'd say let's in Hamburg but
I think there is a different culture
which which we might have in that
respect in Europe all right let's bring
in shamak a gababa yong on this issue of
the the mindset of new agents that you
can see you can see Germany from your
window you can almost say since after
all it's possible you have a tramway
line that runs to Canada on the German
side you heard that he'll convince heat
there you heard martin van marshall is
there a French mindset that makes it
harder to observe the rules well I don't
think so maybe I just can say before
before answering your question that may
be the first difference between France
and Germany was the the attitude facing
this crisis in Germany they adopted a
massive testing strategy and a more
loose lockdown in France we have we not
a massive testing strategies because
tests were reserved for health care
people and I'm going there we are
several chances and now we have a
general lockdown that may last something
about two months maybe more song some
people said I'm I agree with Daniel
that you can keep people this way and
there is no evidence today
apart from statistical models then the
general lockdown is better than a
specific leg down so I think that we
should in other countries be able to up
to have a massive testing strategies so
PCR or serologic tests and then and then
proceed by specified lockdown maybe and
treats treat people you can treat and at
the end I can say that I don't think
there is a difference between France and
Germany I think what is different it's
the political discourse of the president
back home and what the German president
say I think we need to move from fear to
trust we should trust people we should
trust in in their in their understanding
and they can understand and they can do
better than what we think they can do
yeah when Walter Steinmeier spoke 10
days back he seemed to be almost taking
the did get a menu and make home for
employing martial language in his
initial speeches we're gonna talk more
about that in a moment
first off northwest of where CEO mark is
there is the lohan border town of
Carling and there they've been keeping
one essential service open it's a report
from France 24 comms web desk by Sam
ball
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by those people near their book a
magazine just is not the control no it's
too passive option you know a revocable
through a lot with no sleep I cannot
normally really control over a log scale
on the firm at not secure up of the
panel
revelation maneuver telephony P you know
my packages are either drop of the time
the Cote d'Ivoire
[Music]
obviously in here in the church
contingent entrance with a lot of
Bachmann Carlina McAfee ocean that knew
but she had center in Hawley pantech
arise water would cause us films that
acreage is leapin so just be able to
force these Mareeba incite the Dutch
Constitution one shaft maken via and
online under article under Oh Museum
happy she targets goodies
[Music]
[Music]
so a great example there of how
innovative people can become in a crisis
necessity being the mother of invention
but as you mentioned baton fund marshal
in fact the border closures have caused
a good deal of disruption serious
disruption what would you say looking at
cross-border cooperation as a whole how
healthy is franco-german solidarity in
general basically I think we France and
Germany always have different views on
things but as we discuss together we can
find a compromise and if we reach a
compromise this often can be a model for
the other member states of the European
Union to follow that is basically how I
would like to subscribe our partnership
a very specific partnership of course is
the one we're having between houses and
southwestern Germany specifically Baden
because we are almost the same culture
historically and therefore I really am
very sad about the fact that we have had
the borders closed and this can't go on
as I said in the beginning we must open
again these borders of course under
maintaining strict standards of hygienic
measurement measures that is quite clear
but we must meet again because that is
the reason why in Europe
we build friendships we have the
Schengen area all people can move can
get together we have these students in
the Erasmus programme Europe has built a
community of common values of of
democracies and
that is the reason why we can maintain
that only if we come together if we talk
together and if you have for us
you talk in a different way about your
neighbor you even might have prejudices
and you talk about people in which
sooner or later you will not know
anymore and that is what we have to
avoid and therefore in our cross-border
corporation
I will fight for opening the borders
again quite soon dr. Schumacher gababa
ie after spending the last few days at
emergency dispatch in spas boo are you
in favor of reopening the border well I
think we we have or later we have to
reopen the border and but with what we
should do first is a massive testing
strategy and finding the best way to do
it it is serological tests are we do we
trust all the serological tests and some
studies are being conducted this
university how do you hurt much marshals
say that's gonna take time are you
saying in the interim keep the border
shut well I think the border can reopen
after the elegant of may after the end
of the general left on in France I think
it will be it will be a day for the
reopening but not sooner I think all
right in his recent interview with the
Financial Times a minion Mike hole
repeated what he said in a national
broadcast here in France a week ago that
is that coming out of this crisis
humanity would be rethinking its
priorities and that includes he says the
European Union sincerity he consistent
service in renewable pain Itabashi
politic un projet damashii unique no
more transit and Port Authority
consistent with a politic double naman
head of kamyshev you get a notion of
solidarity
[Music]
we adore individual opinion superb aquos
akwimos saw me sit if you don't if you
don't so let me ask first of all my
tampon Marshall and then Daniel
cohn-bendit whether you agree with the
French president and what that means
quite concretely Europe's moment of
truth more solidarity is Germany going
to have to put a lot more money on the
table to ensure you recovery well I
think we are about to do that the the
oil euro finance ministers have agreed
on three points first to strengthen the
European Stability Mechanism so that
countries that might have difficulties
to get access to money which could be
true for especially for Italy would have
easily access to the ESM that is the
first thing then the second that is for
our companies is a credit program from
the European Investment Bank which i
think is very important for small for
medium-sized for big companies and then
the third thing is the so-called sure
program that is to support people that
for the moment being have no work but
that could return to their original job
and in this meantime need some support
and all these three programs Germany is
prepared to give guarantees these
guarantees sum up to quite a big amount
of billions of euros and I think that is
the first step the second step will be
of course a recovery program which we
might include in the next multi-annual
financial framework of the European
Union and of course Germany as biggest
contributor in the European Union of net
amount because now the United Kingdom
has left us we are alone the biggest net
pair there will of course continue to be
in solitary
with those that are weaker and I think
these are important steps we are taking
but of course we need to continue
because it is also in our and the German
interest that the complete eurozone and
that the European Union maintains stable
that's where a lot of German exports go
Daniel cohn-bendit noticeable by
omission in that list that Matan for
marshal just gave us are of course joint
European bonds to fund recovery isn't it
time for Germany to give up its
long-standing resistance to
mutualization of debt at least debt that
will be incurred in future for recovery
from this pandemic well when we heard
mr. marshal we see the problem he said
we are Germany is the biggest net player
Germany is the biggest net winner of the
European Union not only the biggest net
failure and I think that all the debate
now is you have to make understand
psychologically what it means for Italy
and what it means for Spain or Portugal
or Greece or even other country the
problem is that the Italian will they
want to hear that for the recovery fund
Germany Holland sweet Sweden they are
prepared to risk something for the
recovery and this is what I missed by
Chancellor Merkel speech that is a yes
of course we will do solidarity but we
won't risk something in a situation like
this to put it common a fund for
recovery is that Germany we take with
France with Italy with Spain with the
others the risk of the big that the mr.
Dabrowski the Commissioner he talks
about one in half
billion for the recovery you can't do
this only if all the country up we are
ready to to guarantee this fund for the
recovery and to say we guarantee we'd
say we share the risk this is what the
people in Italy in Spain and other where
they want to hear the share of the risk
of the rediscovery sharing the risk
Madame van marshal you could change the
name if you like will there be at the
end some deal I noticed by the way
Emmanuel Michael in his interview that
interview with the Financial Times seem
to be hinting that yeah there's
something in the works between France
and Germany is Germany ready to take
that risk that Daniel cohn-bendit talks
about I must make very clear that we are
taking big risk because these three
programs which I mentioned before in the
ESM the European Investment Bank and the
issuer program for work of mean that we
guaranteed more than 10 billion euros
which we are prepared to lose in the
worst case and all these three programs
are not meant to support Germany but I
meant to support those who have big
difficulties now but what I was
mentioning when I was talking about the
future recovery plans I think that we
will be able to find a way that the
European Commission that is also true
for the sure program for the workers can
can emit money of course the member
states because the European Union has
not a proper budget but only the member
states have proper national budgets the
member states must always guarantee
their and then the amount of guarantees
and therefore also the amount the volume
of risk for Germany in the future will
be a lot bigger but
we point out one thing to the euro once
I am absolutely convinced that even if
we would have a majority in the German
parliament the Constitutional Court in
Germany would not accept such a
legislation because it exceeds it goes
over the responsibilities we as
parliamentarians for the national budget
cannot do what in Europe is known as
bail out we can not give the budget - -
to Europe it is our own national
responsibility and then I'm quite
curious to see how our debates of these
three programs which I mentioned before
will be going on in the Bundestag but
I'm very sure that the Constitutional
Court will not accept would not accept
such a decision then you can binge eat
the buck stops at Germany's
Constitutional Court
no because it's completely wrong you
have two things first we have to
increase the European budget by own
incomes you have the co2 incomes co2 own
income means not that Germany pay more
that France fame or that Italy pray more
but that they are own incomes of Europe
and this can be the co2 attacks it kept
the plastic text the digital text and
this would be an enormous increase of
the European budget and with this type
of increase you can guarantee more for
the recovery cup and there the the the
German cause has nothing to say because
you have own resources export import in
Europe is their own resource it doesn't
go to the one of the other countries so
this is the first thing the second thing
is a recovery fund a Recovery Fund
in this situation will be guaranteed by
the European Central Bank and if the
Europeans entered by guarantee the
European [ __ ] always backed the politics
of the European Central even if the
German central bank said it's not
constitutional so I'm not so afraid of
the jury this is a trick and surrogate
mother is a traitor let me know with the
night at the time let me cut that part
of the discussion right there because
I'd like to bring in dr. cm ik bye-bye
now toward the end of the program to ask
for your view dr. barbay on how the EU
can play a constructive role in recovery
you are sitting there in Strasbourg in
the city where the EU Parliament
normally meets in fact it did not hold
its last session in March
it is currently closed and now the EU
has offered to the city of Strasbourg to
do copan 19 testing at the facilities of
the parliament beyond that gesture what
do you think is needed from the EU well
first I have to thank our German
colleagues who have accepted transfers
of patient in the ICU beds and
permitting us doing the continuing doing
our job and saving people
for the remaining ICU beds so that was
really a really quite act and I want to
thank German German people German
authorities and German colleagues what
we need now and when I heard the
discussion between between our two
invited is that what can European Union
do for for European people what we need
to hear is that what Europe mean to me
what can it change how Europe can change
our health care system how Europe can
change the situation of the people god
bless their job entrepreneur
entrepreneurs how how Europe can help
people who are homeless so how we can
move from what was the division
of economic Europe how can we move
forward who are more integrated maybe
more federal and maybe more political
Europe which in which the social part
and the ecological questions will be a I
think what we must meet in the next in
the next years the great citizens of
Stars Buu are in our thoughts
siamak a gababa they're the heart of it
all those first responders that you
yourself work with every day I want to
thank you so much for joining us today
from the outpatient capital I want to
thank as well Mattern van Marshall for
being with us from Berlin Daniel
cohn-bendit in Frankfurt I'm false puppy
cow for france24 in Paris and I am
Melinda crane for Deutsche Welle in
Berlin and let me say thank you as well
to all of our viewers for joining us on
this premiere this joint edition of the
debate we're glad you could be with us
and we hope to see you again soon bye
bye